you know i was watching the super bowl
ad they did a cable guy
with jim carrey yep and i was thinking
to you immediately i said hey does ben
know about this
because cable guy's yours and also i was
thinking you know that movie has turned
into such a classic and people talk
about it all the time but when it came
out it had to be shitty because it
wasn't a big box office success right
that's that's putting it mildly yeah
right it tanked it
was reviled yeah and jim carrey was
coming off three big movies like
ridiculous movies and he's trusting his
career with you and you're the director
and blah blah blah do you feel
vindicated when you see that super bowl
ad and you go look at this this movie i
knew it was good i knew people would
eventually like it and were you
consulted on that uh ad
um i was not consulted on the ad
right but jim jim sent me a text i think
like two days before and said hey dude
this is a super cool ad coming up
um
i love jim and um
you know and it was it was surprising to
me because uh
you know i thought oh wow they're gonna
go with cable guy you know that's and i
could i could see the tie-in obviously
in terms of the streaming world and all
that
and it was kind of cool that it yeah
yeah there was that moment like okay
it's great that this still exists on
some level in people's psyches i think
most people probably young people
watching were like what the hell is this
you know
but
so what um right it doesn't matter the
character was funny yeah and when we did
it people sort of had the same reactions
the first time yeah
you know so and it was a move that jim
made at a time when he could really you
know he was able to make any movie he
wanted and he committed fully you know
but jim has a certain um confidence in
what he does you talk about confidence
and making choices and
it's he really it's really genuine and
he loves doing it he loves
he loves that character and we laughed
so much making that movie um
making the movie was one of the most fun
experiences i've ever had